live local now now this is eight news
now
live at six live local now
good evening governor sysolak says the
kovat 19 delta variant is spreading like
wildfire and he's exploring measures to
try and address it thanks for joining us
here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm christian casadas he says a
covet 19 vaccine requirement
is being examined and considered for
public colleges
and universities in nevada and for
health care workers and other
others working with vulnerable
populations like the homeless community
he says he's asking his medical advisors
how to make
large gatherings safer he's also
pleading with nevadans
to get vaccinated unlike previous waves
of this virus
we have a real solution this time the
covid19
vaccines that's our solution the
governor pointing out that nearly all
hospitalizations from covet 19 are from
patients
who are not vaccinated well taking a
look now at the latest numbers in the
pandemic right now over 1200 people
are hospitalized across the state nevada
health response also reporting 26 deaths
and 1 135 new cases 936 of today's cases
and
24 of the deaths came from right here in
clark county
now while there are many vaccinations or
i should say locations to get a vaccine
demand
is also really growing right now for
testing in fact many of you reached out
to us on where to go to get tested
because a lot of appointments are
already booked joe mohler joining us now
live from unlv where drive-thru testing
and vaccines are available and this
one's interesting because it goes into
the evening
and joe people that you spoke with want
more locations that are similar to this
one
yeah people who are feeling sick who are
possibly exposed to someone who has the
virus say
they want to get their tests done but
it's not exactly the easiest thing to do
to make that appointment we're at the
unlv location this evening take a live
look this just started here at
5 30 about 30 minutes ago this is a
testing
and a vaccination location that just
started last night
and last night there were about three
quarters of the visitors here that were
trying to get tested
this clinic started last night and will
be closed tomorrow and saturday but then
we'll start again on sunday
through next thursday it will happen in
the evenings like it is this evening
as the pandemic slowed the need for
testing did but now people are wanting
to get tested as
the delta variant becomes a reality some
people are waiting hours for rapid tests
at certain locations while others wait
days for their appointments and results
i caught up with some folks earlier
today at csn campus today where they
were testing we're testing what's
happening and they say they want more
locations to get it done
it takes a while to really search and
find it and
find a place that has appointments
available they're advertising so much
about getting vaccinated getting
vaccinated
where you need to be tested as well even
though you may be vaccinated
the site here is first come first serve
again testing and vaccines the hope here
is that
if you are getting tested and not
vaccinated you will roll up your sleeve
as well now back out here live i want to
give you an idea just how many people
are out here you can see this line
uh happening here but then i'm going to
have our photojournalist tim
spanned to the left here and you can see
this actually wraps around the entire
parking lot and this is another line of
people waiting to get their
their shot or their vaccine this ends
tonight at 10 30 and will again
open up on sunday and go through next
thursday we do have a list of
more information on this side and a list
of other locations up on our website
that is 8newsnow.com
reporting live at unlv this evening joe
mullen good news now very busy sight
there thank you joe well you might
recently have heard of the term delta
plus
it's the new variant that health
officials say it just popped up on the
radar
today we spoke to unlv's epidemiologist
brian lavis who tells us
viruses mutate all the time which is the
case of this new covated substrate
this spreads more easily and causes the
same effects once it enters your body
in other words he says you produce more
of the virus which allows you to spread
it faster
according to the washington post few
cases have been reported
in the united kingdom india and here in
the u.s liba says
a big concern for doctors will happen
this winter
as different respiratory diseases start
to circulate as we get back together and
start to do things
that we didn't do last year we have the
potential for multiple viruses
circulating at the same time including
all the common cold viruses we deal with
and influenza uh so in addition to just
dealing with one enemy we have multiple
to deal with at the same time and can
also be challenging for clinicians who
now have to differentiate between
covet flu and the other things that
could be circulating in our community
leyva says a booster of the copet 19
vaccine could help immunity but the
bigger problem he says
is logistics right now health officials
are still focusing on getting people
their first shot
a booster would mean getting those
millions of people already vaccinated
to return for another he says we are not
at a critical point to be rolling this
out yet
and taking a live look right now at the
vax nevada days drawing
tonight one lucky winner the big cash
prize tonight will be
50 thousand dollars four other people
will win
25 000 and 10 people will win a thousand
dollars each
plus there are also a number of tuition
prizes and fishing licenses as well so
we'll be keeping an eye on that for you
throughout the evening well denise the
silverton casino and hotel will be
offering vaccine appointments tomorrow
they will also be offering appointments
on the 12th and the 27th
from 8 to 11 am both the pfizer and the
johnson and johnson shots
will be available of course we have a
link to schedule an appointment on our
website
eight newsnow dot com
in less than three weeks tokyo will host
the paralympics
another big event that will welcome more
than 4 000 athletes from 98 different
countries
this coming though as the positive covet
case numbers grow in that city
along with frustration from its citizens
matt barnes reports from tokyo
just three days left in the olympics but
then the page will turn to the
paralympics as the international olympic
committee
and the city of tokyo try to balance
once again competition and coronavirus
i have been a very late convert to being
convinced that this is all going to
take place uh but hey it looks like it
looks like we're going to do it and i'm
glad
glad it was training like it was going
to go on the whole time blake hexton is
set to leave for tokyo in two weeks as
he prepares for a second paralympics
like many he's closely watching the
olympics you know as the guy watching on
tv i think it's been great i mean i've
gotten to see
competitions it seems like everything's
going off fairly smooth um
following along with some of my friends
on the olympic team things are
definitely weird
and that has blake also watching the
covet case numbers which hit record
highs both inside and outside of the
olympic village this week
it is the most tested community anywhere
in the world and i think that the
japanese people can take a great deal of
confidence
in that the ioc maintains the positivity
rate is low among games related
personnel
meanwhile the numbers in tokyo are
surging and the number of hospital beds
are dwindling
we have great deal of sympathy we
understand that we all come from similar
situations a lot of us
in our own countries so of course we
have a great deal of empathy
and that is why we are carrying on to
give
the japanese people such confidence in
what we're doing for blake
he is just controlling what he can
control he is fully vaccinated and
spending these final days in the us
training and isolating good to be honest
with you just trying to stay away
stay away from people as much as i can
and and then you just kind of hope for
the best i mean
you know it's kind of the story of 2020
right like you take the precautions you
can and then
you know whatever happens happens in
tokyo i'm matt barnes
[Music]
happening tomorrow nhp trooper micah may
will be laid to rest
he died last week after he was hit by a
carjacking suspect turning
during a chase on the i-15 may was 46
years old and is survived by his wife
and two children now the procession will
begin at 9 30 a.m
at palm mortuary in downtown and it will
end at central
christian church in henderson where the
funeral service will be held
that starts at 11 o'clock now there will
also be a second procession after the
funeral to palm eastern mortuary and
cemetery
well this week mccarran airport as well
as airports really across the country
were plagued with flight delays and
cancellations spirit airlines one of the
airlines hit the hardest
yesterday in a statement they said quote
we've dealt with overlapping operational
challenges
including weather system outages and
staffing shortages
and that caused widespread
irregularities on our operation and
impacted crew scheduling then they went
on to say they expected the
cancellations to drop today but there
have still been a lot of delays so
if you're heading that way make sure to
check your flight status
well if you're looking to do something
pretty cool the mob museum
is hosting a new program on the 25th
anniversary of the murder of tupac it
will feature panelists and a discussion
on the rapper
co-founder of the rap group public enemy
chuck d
will be speaking on tupac's cultural
legacy and the impact of his death
now this is happening on september 1st
at 8 30 pm
and tickets are on sale for 75 dollars
well next at six o'clock a heartbreaking
story of a grandmother searching for
answers
the i-team digs into the mysterious
death of a child placed
in foster care and wildfires are raging
out of control on the west new video
from one california town that was just
leveled by flames nate denise the
excessive heat warning is about to go
away we'll talk about wind we've also
got slightly cooler tips in your most
accurate weather now weekend forecast
right around the corner live
to my silver state refrigeration and
hvac
questions surround the death of a
newborn baby who died in foster care
now the i-team has uncovered a document
which reveals the foster parents were
previously investigated for neglect
in an unrelated case more than two years
ago now in this exclusive interview the
child's grandmother is looking for
answers
as vanessa murphy reports this isn't the
first tragedy for the family this year
this is eci joelle the only thing
that you want is justice this is eci's
grandmother
she's asked the i-team to protect her
identity
last april her daughter was stabbed to
death in a parking lot right in front of
her
metro police say the killer is her
ex-boyfriend
she was a new mom to baby isaiah the
grandmother says
child protective services or cps took
custody of the infant
the same day she says she expected they
would soon be reunited
and in the meantime she prepared to
permanently care for him
i need my grandson back because
i'm going to be ready okay
to help him she says she repeatedly
reached out to a cps caseworker to
ask to be reunited with her grandson i
am ready to get him
and ready and i was very happy
okay he never returned my
messages she tells the i-team she
finally received a call from the clark
county coroner's office
he said no i have bad news for you
and he told me that he's dead i scream
i scream i was very mad
she says no details about the child's
death were shared with her
the i-team dug for answers and found
that according to the coroner's office
at two months and 14 days old isaiah
died at
university medical center after an
incident in the master bedroom of a
foster family assigned to care for him
that's 26 days after the grandmother
says cps took custody of him
aci's cause of death is pending we also
obtained this child fatality disclosure
which states the department of family
services received a report
that the child had been found
unresponsive in his crib by his foster
parent
it also states that the same foster
parents were previously investigated
a report was received alleging neglect
in 2018
for at least one other child in their
care the allegations in that case were
found
unsubstantiated our clients need to
know what happened attorney andre lago
marcino is representing the family
although a lawsuit has not been filed
they need to proceed
with all the natural processes of
grieving and
getting answers the i-team reached out
to cps for answers
in an email a spokesman wrote that cps
is awaiting the coroner's report
the foster parents have not been charged
their license is on hold and under
investigation and they currently do not
have any foster children
when we asked why cps isn't sharing
information with a grandmother
we were told that confidentiality
requirements preclude cps from sharing
information with her
without parental consent again the
child's father is charged with murder
records show he's currently going to be
transferred to a mental health facility
and the child's mother was killed as she
grieves the loss of her daughter
the grandmother is in disbelief about
the loss of her grandson
in my heart i think she's not dead
it's not easy it's very hard i love him
vanessa murphy 8 news now
you heard vanessa talk there about
excuse me parental consent
apparently she followed up with three
additional emails asking cps about the
confidentiality regarding the child
since the mother is dead and according
to records the father has been declared
not competent for trial
however no additional response or
explanation was given